[Music]
welcome to the week in 60 minutes from
spectator tv recorded on thursday
december the 10th
on the show today the latest in the
brexit negotiations
from the spectators home team plus
philip rycroft former permanent
secretary
at the department for exiting the eu
deal or no deal what should labor do
about
it political editor of the new statesman
stephen bush
sheds light on labour's renewed brexit
civil war
there's still no escaping covert wales
looks like it's about to go into
a renewed lockdown i'll speak to a
former leader of the welsh conservatives
to find out why infections there just
aren't going down
and as the uk began vaccinating with the
pfizer jab this week it's not
the first country in the world to have
started china has already vaccinated one
million of its people
but the vaccines haven't had regulatory
approval
we'll speak to cindy you host of the
spectators chinese whispers podcast
to find out what's going on a reminder
to subscribe to the spectators youtube
channel for free
then you'll never miss a show on
spectator tv just hit the subscribe
button
in the bottom right corner as always a
special thanks to charles stanley
for supporting this week's episode of
the week in 60 minutes
charles stanley is one of the uk's
leading wealth management firms
and one of the oldest companies on the
london stock exchange
so first brexit no point in speculating
since
nobody really knows though the move
music has become
increasingly downbeat this week i'm
joined by the spectators
political editor james forsythe and the
deputy political editor kitty balls
welcome
to you both james what do we now think
happened
at the johnson van der leyen dinner
uh on wednesday night in brussels so i
think over
scallops and turbot no no coincidence
there was quite so much fish served
i think the two sides set out their
positions
and but i don't think what happened over
dinner was that they
they spotted any potential landing zones
or compromises
so michelle barnier and david frost are
going away to talk again until sunday
but they are still trying to find
solutions
rather than trying to see how a solution
could work in terms of legal text or the
like
so we are still quite a way away and
they are still
i mean these two sides are paradoxically
very close
but also very far apart basically
everything is done apart from
i think essentially two questions one is
this whole issue of the so-called
ratchet claws
you know what happens if the eu
increases its standards
and the uk doesn't follow suit and fish
i think those two issues are
you know and they have been the issues
for weeks now but they are the two
remaining issues
the question is by sunday can they make
progress on
on either of those i think if you if
they make any progress on either of
those
i think that johnson and mandela will
tell the negotiators to keep going
they'll try and give the talks another
push because
i think that uh neither side wants to be
the one who looks like they are
responsible for
uh no deal for saying right that's it
the talks are done
over uh there's no agreement
so the real deadline in the end isn't
all the ones that the media has been
setting or even
the government in britain or brussels
has implied the real deadline in the end
is midnight on the 31st of december well
a few days earlier than that because
some legislation would need to go
through both the european parliament and
the uk parliament but yeah
i mean i i think that you know you are
essentially correct that the only
deadline now that matters
is the end of a transition period and
what can be done
by then and i think that you you will i
think there's also just
the question is can you get any momentum
into these negotiations and i think that
kind of
the question is i think what some people
hoped is that last night might create
some some fresh ways of thinking about
these issues
it didn't do that but there will be
another johnson wonderland conversation
on sunday
james the british have already said that
when it comes to one of the sticking
points of
the rules the regulations um the state
stops the regime now the british have
already said
when it comes to rules and regulation
there will be no regression
that that what currently exists will be
a base
and that we would not go back from that
or resolve from that
but the europeans as i understand it is
saying that's fine but we also want
what's called dynamic alignment
we want you to stay aligned with our
rules
as we change them through the 2020s and
beyond
um do the europeans
do they realize that if the british
agreed to that position
there would be no real point in leaving
the european union
yeah i think the issue is how do you
manage that
if the uk doesn't follow suit and as you
say if the uk was simply going to do
everything that the eu does
what would be the point in leaving it uh
so the question is how do you manage
that question and
i think at the moment the eu wants a
system where
it could be judge and jury as to whether
the uk was seeking to undercut the eu by
not following these standards and impose
uh punitive measures unilaterally
but what it also wants is the uk to sign
up to
not responding to those unilateral
measures with measures of its own so it
is
essentially trying to unilaterally
disarm the uk
and get the uk to commit to unilateral
disarmament ahead of any future trade
war
and declare itself to be judge and jury
in that dispute
now i think you know in some ways the
inherent
uh unreasonableness of that position
suggests that there is some room for
compromise here you know
what what about what would if you had a
system of reciprocity where both sides
could respond if they felt the other was
behaving unfairly
towards them you know that that's not
the most stable basis for a relationship
but could that be the basis for an
agreement and avoid
the reality of tariffs from the 1st of
january
casey we're hearing the british prime
minister setting up what's been called a
no deal unit
i thought they already had a no deal
unit and michael gove
was sort of in charge of it so what are
they talking about
yes so this is a a further exploration
in terms of a no deal units so we have
had michael gove leading all the no deal
preparations
these various committees um you know for
months now
but this is now daily updates to the
prime minister from a group of civil
servants within 10 downing street
on no deal preparations but it's
actually part of a wider issue
on a wider project which is just winter
and how bad winter
is looking for the government so you
have the no deal updates which is in
case we do leave out a deal
and that is the case in january but also
combined
and going along with that a general
updates about the risks that the
government is braced for
in the new year from everything from
flooding uh
to more issues with covert because the
worry is that we've already seen how
much pressure the state commit
came under it in the first stage of the
pandemic and there's a real concern that
ultimately the system will not be able
to cope if lots of things go wrong at
once
james the eu has a summit today
and uh tomorrow starts today and
continues into tomorrow
uh will brexit figure at all or the
inability to get
any kind of breakthrough between the uh
president of the european uh commission
and the british prime minister
does that mean it doesn't figure at all
or will the british still be hoping i
mean they've often indicated they want
some kind of
nation-state intervention by which i
think in general
they mean that chancellor merkel leans
on
president macron not to be so
intransigent on fish and so on
is any of that likely to happen at this
or will
brexit be just the dog that doesn't bark
at this summit
well i think an attempt to preserve eu
unity they've been very keen to keep
brexit
off the agenda i think all there will be
is an ursula wonderland update on her
conversation with boris johnson
last night i i think that's not
necessarily a bad thing i mean the
danger is that if last night had spied
some potential compromises
and urself wonderland had come and told
the eu council about them
but the french and the belgium's who
lead the most
hard line on both fish and level playing
field might have kind of shot them down
straight away i think the question is
whether in the margins they're obviously
going to be talking about this
you know whether you begin to get some
movement i also think that
there might be some movement after this
summit because this summit on the
european side
has been dominated by this question
about what to do about hungary and
poland
what to do about sanctions on turkey and
the whole issue of the
the eu's climate change targets you know
once this summit is over angela merkel
is very methodical
she can kind of brexit then becomes the
last issue
in the entry of the german uh presidency
of the eu council which he currently
holds
so the question is do you get some push
then uh on those issues towards a
compromise
and i think that the kind of question
here is this is the commission have been
very protective of their role in the
negotiation
they basically kept saying to the brits
don't speak to the nation states
we are your interlocutors in this
negotiation
i think if that is the case the
commission needs to be a bit more
confident
about saying to the nation say it's
right this is
if you want a deal this is the deal that
can be done
okay katie what what is the constraint
on the prime minister's side
what is it if if he can what is it that
he can seeks and then creates a whole
mass of trouble for himself on the tory
back benches well
what are their what are they looking for
to begin a rebellion
well i think first things first he is in
a much stronger position than theresa
may of his party
for several reasons uh partly that
majority of 80
but also just the fact that i think
since he has become prime minister
even his tory leadership campaign his
decision to resign as foreign secretary
there is a general sense of trusting the
prime minister to a degree
in terms of his natural instincts on
brexit which theresa may never had
that said there are clearly some nervous
tory mps and there is the possibility
that if he does bring back a brexit deal
there will be a sizable rebellion
i still think it's unlikely it would
stop anything from passing
and but you could see that and i think
for the european research group uh they
put out a statement saying they you know
supported the prime minister
but it was slightly menacing i think
when it started talking about how
there's nothing to fear from freedom
and a slight reminder of the red lines
for them i think they will uh bill cash
will be
studying the legal texts very carefully
and i think that anything on sovereignty
is going to be
something that that if they do not feel
there's a clear enough uh
cut cutaway that is going to be a strong
issue from them diverging is very key
i think though boris johnson does feel
pretty strongly on that but that's
something they will be looking at
closely
and then i think that fisheries is an
issue because
ultimately you can to a degree fudge the
language around some of this stuff so
uh arbitration and others i think that
there is a sense boris johnson if he
believes it is good
can get lots of mps on the side by
telling them why he thinks that
fisheries is much harder to fudge i
think that if you have a situation where
we hear the figures in terms of the
quota in terms of the return
catch and they just sound quite measly
and there's not much you can do to
sugarcoat that and i think that's why
it's one of the hardest issues
politically
and yes you have the erg but on top of
this you have
red wall mps some of whom i understand
are talking about sending one of those
letters to boris johnson saying you know
do not surrender stay on task and
also particularly on fisheries he has
scottish tory mps
who are saying that ultimately they need
something they can sell in scotland they
need a tangible benefit
and it's really important that there is
something which is clearly a win there
so i think that those are the two areas
where you can start to see rebellion
growing
as for no deal i think there are a
handful of one nation mps
who would be very unhappy if that's
where you got to but i think you
probably have more rebels
on the other side if it's an
unsatisfactory deal
than if he goes for no deal i think that
is a smaller rebellion
are they all relishing the prospect of
uh
meeting on boxing day
it's definitely some nervous story mps
particularly because recess dates have
not yet been confirmed
but i think that they're hoping that
even even traditionalists are hoping
that perhaps
the proxy technical voting system could
come in useful there
all right james and katie for the moment
thank you very
much let's go now to philip rycroft he
was
uh permanent secretary of the department
of exiting
the eu philip welcome to the spectator
tv
was it always going to be this difficult
not necessarily it's not surprising that
it's been quite
tough and this is it's an important
relationship for both sides probably
the most important relationship
certainly on trade but also
on issues uh like internal security and
so on
so there's a huge amount to play for but
of course we have these big arguments of
principle
which are causing the blockage now and
that's has been described already
on the one hand the uk saying we left in
order to be able to set our own rules
on the other side the eu saying you want
privileged access to our market
obligations come with that in the way
that you manage your own
regulatory environment but since this
is now even if we get a deal it looks
like it's going to be a
pretty skinny deal it's not going to be
this canada plus plus that we were
uh talking about nearby it may not even
be canada we
we've been calling it canada dry on this
if it is so skinny why is the eu
insisting that we remain aligned
in so many ways with whatever the eu
does
well it is in in uh contrast to
being in the single market it's a skinny
deal but as a trade deal it would be one
of the more advanced
that the eu has done particularly of
course on tariff and quotas that would
be the big win
uh no and quotas uh for uk
businesses trading with the eu and vice
versa and the eu side has said all along
through this and this isn't a new
position
and you're not like canada you're a lot
closer you do a lot more trade with us
and we are therefore commensurately
more worried about you trading unfairly
with us that's the position they've
taken
we have to remember that the single
market is essentially a jewel in the eu
crown the legal construct that gives
life and meaning to being a member of
the eu which is why they protect it
um so fiercely the eu as a construct is
designed
to look after the interests of its own
member states
not of third parties and that's hence
the caution
in seeking to strike a deal with a close
and important trade in partner like the
uk
so when it came to the free trade deal
with canada
and although that was not entirely
tariff free
or entirely quote it was a pretty uh
a lot of stuff the terrorists came away
and the quarters came away it was a
pretty decent as free trade deals go
this was a pretty decent and extensive
free trade deal
the eu did not insist that uh canada's
state subsidy regime had to fall in line
with the eu
although there had to be dynamic
alignment of canada's rules and
regulations
with the eu i think a lot of british
people won't understand
why you insist yeah well we're closer
but so what
uh most of our economy is services and
services are not
geo-specific um they won't understand
why the british are being treated
differently from the canadians
sure obviously that's been a big part of
the arguments all the way through this
and
the assumption on on many people's part
that the eu
is being unreasonable away from the
you looked at from where we are now we
are now a third country
now we want this privileged access to
their market
uh of course the the eu is perfectly
free sovereign if you like to set the
conditions
for that and i come back to the point
the concern
as i understand it i don't speak for the
eu clearly
is because of the proximity and
proximity
still matters in trade terms and because
of the volume of trade
that they worry about the the uk
stealing a a march on eu-based
businesses
by allowing a different set of standards
to emerge either side of the channel but
the eu runs a
massive trade surplus well actually runs
a overall uh current account surplus
with the uk
but it particularly runs a massive trade
surplus in traded goods
uh with the with the uk it would have to
be one hell of a change in britain's
rules and
regulations to den that very much i mean
this is not a straw man
well i i wonder actually from both sides
of the
of this argument whether in three or
four years time particularly if we land
up with no deal we'll look back and
think
what was all that fuss about and if you
if you think about it
exactly your point it would take some
really
big divergence in standards to have a
material impact on trading conditions
but if you look at it from a uk
perspective the government's already
said we accept non-regression so we're
not going to lower
existing standards and if you think of
things like environment the government
they're keen to push on
on climate change so improving standards
is a good thing
and even if our standards are somewhat
different from the eu's
uh when you roll forward five ten years
time
it seems very likely that the eu and the
uk will still be
running similar levels of standards
because that's what developed mature
civilized modern economies will do
the one thing that stands out of that of
course is state aid
where the uk has been very insistent uh
on freedom to spend more money
supporting businesses
paradoxically because it's always been
the uk that has been the biggest
proponent
of control of state aid at the eu level
and france and germany within the rule
still spend
a lot more money on state aid than the
uk does
and so one again has to question the
motivations there
i mean i speak as somebody who was a
civil servant for 30 odd years worked
quite a lot on the business side of
things the state at the end of the day
is generally not the best place to
determine
um you know which are the winners in the
future economy
in other words the uk moving into a
position where it wants to splash
a lot of taxpayers cash around on
businesses sort of
shades of the 1970s and british leyland
there and i wonder again in three or
four years time where people will look
back and say
oh you know wasn't that a bit of a red
herring to point another phrase
fisheries i think we can sort out by the
way
uh i never thought i would uh see a
stumbling block for a tory government to
be
the the right to dole out lots of state
aid
but has there been have these talks from
the start
phillip been characterized by a certain
mutual mutual incomprehension
yes i and i think also a lack of trust
and i think that lack of trust has been
there um
all the way through but was exacerbated
of course by the uk internal market bill
happily now those clauses uh that
offended the eu and indeed other
international partners have now
have now been withdrawn but i think
there has been this mutual
incomprehension on the eu side what has
driven brexit
and from the uk side a misunderstanding
of how the eu operates and where
the deep concerns of the eu lie and and
that's just not been very helpful
um throughout all of this and it's
perhaps a
signal also of the way in which the uk
through our membership um never really
got sort of integrated into
understanding the operation of the eu
in a way that's second nature to uh to
the the countries that are
more core to that enterprise if we were
to leave on
no deal would the in your view would
there then
quite quickly and by that i mean
sometime next year maybe
after the summer would there be a move
then to try and reopen
the talks and do a free trade deal again
try and get that done
or would would relations actually
both sides may be so angry that
relations could end up in the freezer
for quite some time
yeah three quick things to say about
that one is
um that the eu and the uk will have to
talk about
stuff from here on forever whether we
like it or not including fisheries
common resource
the fish don't respect the median line
they don't get spawned as a british or a
french fish
the stocks move around you have to
manage these resources in common
and there'll be loads of other stuff
where we have to talk second point
uh this relationship is too important
both on trade
and on internal security and on a bunch
of other things not to formalize the
relationship
at some point but third point i agree
with you with you when you say that the
risk is if we have no deal at the end of
this year
tempers will be such and political pride
will be such
that neither side will be willing to be
the one that says oh we need to get
first
we need to get back around the table so
it could be some time
before negotiations resume to put the
relationship
on a sound footing when you
stand back a little bit from trying to
work out
whether we're going to get a deal or no
deal and get away from the incredible
detail that goes in
to these talks uh whether you were for
remain
or whether you were for leave when you
look at
uh how close the eu in the uk
how many areas we will need to cooperate
in the 2020s
and beyond our common interests as well
in or out
of the you know it's our biggest market
we have a common interest
in the eurozone doing well whether we're
in the eu or not
in defense and security and intelligence
and let me just standing up for
democracy
and human rights we have all so much in
common
we we are free traders you know we don't
want tariffs if we can
is it if we don't get a deal is it not
really depressing
that two sides with so much in common
just couldn't do a bloody trade deal yes
and and actually a failure of statecraft
on both sides after four
and a bit years not to be able to manage
that and let's not even know the deal
that's on the table as you described
earlier is quite a thin
deal no deal is damaging it's
economically
damaging for both sides the application
of tariffs
in terms of automotives agri food and so
on even for fisheries is very damaging
all the other agreements fall away like
on internal security
on research and all the rest of it even
australia
i know that people talk about australia
as the no deal destination
even australia has a number of deals
with the eu we would only have one
the withdrawal agreement uh if you think
about short-term disruption at the
border
in an ideal world what is the incentive
on
the part of the eu authorities or the
french authorities
the belgian authorities to play nice but
just one final thought on this which is
i think hugely important for the uk
we've got some really rather important
elections coming up next year
uh in scotland and wales and we know
where opinion is at in scotland
on the question of independence we know
that brexit
and and feeling about brexit in scotland
has been a bit of a driver for that
and no deal brexit uh it seems to me
exacerbates concern within the uk
union about our future direction as a
country
and somebody lives in scotland a lot of
work in scotland
that worries me immensely well you used
to work in government in scotland so
let's finish on scotland because
if you look at what it's taken and we're
not
there yet to unravel a 50-year
uh uh arrangement um
which wasn't it despite what a lot of
the brexiteers said in many areas wasn't
that deep
i mean what is it and we're still four
years out and we've still not left yet
or even come to a deal
if scotland was to vote for independence
in a second referendum
i mean the mind boggles of what these
negotiations would require
unraveling 300 years of union
and countries economies cultures peoples
who have been totally integrated
everywhere you think i mean they're not
going to happen very quickly either
no in a word i absolutely agree with
that and we
we sort of appeared over that uh cliff
edge
back in 2014 uh when the referendum on
scottish independence came quite close
of course of course notoriously the
prime minister of the day david cameron
didn't allow us within whitehall to do
any contingency planning
and for that eventuality but um what i
can say is behind the scenes
particularly after that famous sunday
times poll
that put the yes side ahead there was a
bit of uh
scurrying around in the in the corridors
of whitehall to think
how on earth do we cope literally on day
one
of that result but you're absolutely
right and we did a huge amount of work
describing
the benefits of the uk union for all
parts of the union
we had about 14 or 15 times from
everything from defense
through to the social security system to
culture
to movement of people and so on
dismantling all of that
uh would be an absolutely huge
challenge and would be for the british
state
for the remainder uk would be a
distraction
from everything else that you wish to do
for for for literally
for years um we when we
when brexit happened uh of course again
we didn't we didn't do a lot of
contingency planning
for that either but we know from the
experience
there just what a massive task that was
which started the day after the
referendum and is far from finite finish
now and but scottish independence
would make all of that pale in
comparison
well raycroft was that thought the mind
boggles we'll
leave it there we thank you for your
time and expertise
uh being on spectator tv and we wish you
a very merry christmas
andrew thank you very much thank you
philip rycroft
uh there now before we move on i'd just
like to remind you to subscribe to the
spectators youtube channel
it's free you'll never miss a new
episode of spectator tv because it will
alert you when one is coming up
you just hit the subscribe button in the
bottom right
corner now we stick with brexit but from
a different angle
if there is a deal it will need to be
ratified on both sides
of the channel there are mechanisms
ready to do that on our site
it will be ratified or needs to be by
the commons so if a deal comes before
parliament what should labour do who
better to
update us on this and labor's renewed
brexit strife who would seem than
stephen bush political editor
of the new statesman uh stephen before
we get into some of the detail here just
broadly describe
what the there seems to be some kind of
dividing line on this
even within the shadow cabinet right so
within the shadow cabinet there are
essentially two schools of thought the
thing that they all agree on is that
uh because they do not believe that yeah
they think no deal would be an
utter disaster you can't gamble with the
possibility that you cause it by mistake
if the conservative rebellion is
above expectation so they know that
voting against it is off the table
but within the uh the shadow cabinet you
have a sort of coalition of people who
uh opposed brexit despite being in very
leave seats who have therefore taken a
lot of political risk and are quite
attached to that position
who go well we can't vote for this very
thin deal
we miles away from what we had before we
have to abstain and then you have
long-term committed um opponents of
brexit who feel the same way
then you have uh and i think it's fair
to say a tendency which
is more naturally inclined to kirsten's
position so people who
came to that second referendum position
fairly late late on in 2018
early in 2019 partly when it became
clear that labour could no longer ride
two horses
who to be honest sort of just want to be
able to get rid on this issue
they want to be able to send a clear
signal then they are not going to
unpick brexit and what clearer signal
than to vote for it and of course the
excuse
which is your legitimate issues but the
excuse is the risk of no deal
and that's where the cabinet and i can
see that but
i mean even almost just for the sake of
a quiet life and to
get it out of the way would it not be a
defensible position for kyo starmer to
say
look we we were against uh leaving the
european union
but we know that argument is over
however we're not voting for
a deal because we don't even like this
deal much we're not going to unpick it
we're not going to try and
re-litigate the referendum again
but we're just going to abstain this is
the government's deal
is a government they were the ones that
wanted uh brexit
we are we are not going to vote for it
we're not going to vote against it
it's their it's their deal and
it's not really our issue is that not a
defensible position
i think in a vacuum it's a defensible
position i think the problem that labour
has sort of made for itself
is that under kirsten where they've
abstained on a number of bills and are
tricky for their internal coalition so
they
abstain on a series of bills to do with
increasing the power of the security
services and
changing how they're overseen and i
think that the problem that labour now
have
is that actually the argument you you
describe is impeccable in a vacuum
but i think we're at a stage where it's
quite likely that people go
don't you abstain on everything
difficult when are you ever going to get
off the fence
and i think that's why it becomes a bit
harder and a bit more fraught for labor
to abstain on this one
the problem though for kyostama too if
he is intended
to go down that road is that when it
comes to
the voting of what is essentially an
international treaty
so i think i'm right stephen saying it's
all or nothing they can't put amendments
down
to say you know oh you should change the
fish quarter or
we should have more power over state
subsidies i mean you you either take it
all
or you have to vote against it is is
that correct
well the the actual difficulty is the
treaty itself doesn't need to pass
through parliament
only the implementing legislation and
the reason why that's so difficult for
labor is if the implementing legislation
is
here is our arbitration mechanism well
labor is pro having an arbitration
mechanism and would
sign up to less regulatory autonomy than
the conservatives will get if there is a
deal because they would
trade that for more market access but
what if the implementating legislation
is
here's a huge bunch of powers for the
prime minister for the executive taken
away from parliament
uh to implement not just this trade deal
but every trade deal well that's
quite painful for the labour party to
vote for that so this is why the precise
detail may make this issue more fraught
for labour
so one thing to say will support a deal
quite another to support suede of henry
viii powers
no exactly no i kill so let's get a look
at the shadow uh
uh cabinet situation then the
parliamentary party and then insofar as
we can tell
the party in the in the country how does
the shadow cabinet
divide on this and who are the the major
figures on either side
right so the majority of the shadow
cabinet is in the kind of get on to get
along position on this you know
just vote for it make the issue go away
if it all goes wrong no one remembers
what labour's position on the erm was no
one remembers what george osborne's
position on uh
the 20 2006 uh budget round was right
then there's a group of people who are
actually very well represented
particularly in the shadow treasury team
so both the shadow chief secretaries of
the treasury bridget phillipson who
sits for a very leave constituency and
the shadow chancellor annelise dods who
sits for a very remain constituency are
of the view then
look this deal doesn't work we would
probably want to revisit it to get more
uh yeah to get a greater level of market
access because obviously that underpins
their ability to
spend more money on the public services
so let's not put our hands on it then
you have people like david lammy who
have
long term very committed opponents of
brexit who are also very reluctant
to to back it but crucially rachel
reeves who's
his de facto shadow brexit secretary who
like kierstama someone who was
against stopping brexit for quite a long
time then in 2018
kind of went okay we're clearly stuck
let's go with the sort of vote
maximization approach for labour because
obviously more of their corvo
was remain than leave and still is uh
remain in leave
but those are the kind of key
participants with with kiestarma having
to act as the
the decider within the cabinet and on
the back benches
on the labor back benches uh stephen
is there a risk of a real divide here
that the party could be
uh really if not split down the middle
nevertheless a
big chunk of rebels could defy uh mr
starner
um no i don't think there's all that
much chance the the where
where this kind of gets complicated from
a labor perspective
is um obviously uh kierstama has uh
suspended jeremy corbyn
uh from the parliamentary party because
of his reaction to the hrc report
and that has triggered a bunch of
tit-for-tat reprisals within the labour
party on its left right axis
and so if kierstama votes to however he
whips whether it's abstain or to vote
for
a number of people on the labor left are
going to vote against the deal
uh and i think that means you probably
end up with a rebellion in 30
40s now i don't think that will be a
particularly significant event in the
life of the labour party and if i were
advising the left of the labour party i
would say don't do it you have no
credibility on this
issue right no one thinks oh do you know
who really loves
being a member of the eu the bennite
left right you just look just looks a
bit incoherent
and it but it but so most of the
rebellion will
i think be able to be sort of passed
aside as that kind of thing
the crucial thing is the group of people
in the lay party who really mattered in
terms of their brexit position last time
were people who were frightened of a
liberal democrat revival
and bluntly it doesn't look like that is
a going to be a factor
at the moment but it's really if those
people so people who don't have
particularly strong eu
um convictions but they do have a lot of
students in their seat
fairly leafy parts and used to vote lib
dem if those people start to go oh i
don't like how this is going i don't
like my mailbag
that's when you'd see a big and
disfiguring labour rebellion
let me bring james forsything here who's
been listening to us stephen james
what's your take
on labour's dilemma i i think what kia
osama said at prime minister's questions
when he strongly indicated that labour
would back the deal
is is the actually the only thing for
labour to do because you've got to vote
on what's in
in front of you and the alternative to
this deal would be no deal which dahmer
is on the record as saying that
and also i think stephen is right no one
will remember but labour backed him this
is going to be boris johnson's deal
whatever happens but if he votes against
it he sets
himself up for years of boris johnson
attacks off he still wants to stop
brexit he still hasn't come to terms
with it
and i thought the most striking thing
about pmq's yesterday was how visibly
uncomfortable kia stammer was talking
about brexit normally at prime
minister's questions
boris johnson looks a bit like oh crikey
i've got six
difficult questions from this lawyer
yesterday he was on
much more bullied form because the
subject was brexit and he knows how
uncomfortable starmer is on that issue
so i think kirsten armor you the best
thing to do is is to just
try and kind of as stephen put it get
rid so vote for the deal
and the legislation to put it into law
and and just
hope that you can but the next election
isn't going to be fought on the whole
brexit question again
and and also i think stephen is is right
as well which is
you know yes there are some members of
the shadow capital the parliamentary
party
who are worried about kind of a
pro-remain backlash in their seats but
realistically labour are not going to
lose many seats to the lib dems or
greens
at the next election in 2023 or 2024 on
which way they voted on a brexit deal
while as uh if if there is a deal and
they vote against it
that could be used to hammer them again
in those red wall seats that they lost
last time around
i'll come back to stephen to finish up
and get reaction to that before i do let
me go to katie
uh now katie what are you hearing about
the mood and on the labor side and the
shatter cabinet and on the labor-backed
benches
well i think as steven has explained
very clearly there is that divide
i think another thing in terms of
concern over what kirstama chooses
is i have had some labor mps say to me
that they worry there is a pattern at
the moment of
a labour party that just abstains and
often the position in votes and we've
seen that with lockdown votes
is to abstain and therefore this is a
an issue of the day so i think there is
more of a
pressure to take a strong position but
they worry about a pattern by which you
have a labor leader who yes is doing
well in the polls
but quite quickly could develop a
reputation as someone who doesn't really
have strong stances
or you know chooses things depending on
what's the most politically easy and and
i think
there is a concern at the moment that
you can understand it in terms of the
first year
kirama has faced there's been a lot
changing he hasn't had to do that much
policy
but i think that what i have heard from
some labour mps labour mps who don't
think they will like the deal
is that they don't think it is
sustainable for stammer to keep
abstaining on votes and this is such a
big one that were he to choose to do
that it would
fit a pattern which could be quite
unfavorable to them
stephen final question to you and just
picking up on the points there and
please respond to them i mean would it
be too simple to simply to bring it down
to this if you were kia stammer you
would think
um look if we we
need to win back some of these red wall
seats if we have any chance of
even being the largest party if we vote
against this
deal or even abstain the tories will
just
throw this at us relentlessly and make
it more difficult
to get these red wall seats back they'll
say we can't be trusted
so let's just hold our nose and vote for
it
and then move on stephen yeah i think
that is true and i think it comes back
to
uh james's ex in summary of yesterday's
pmqs right which
you know pmq's itself doesn't matter but
what it does do is it reveals where the
parties are comfortable and where
they're vulnerable
and broadly if the next election can be
about brexit in any way
that's painful for labour and i think
probably fatally painful for labor
it's just impossible to see how they get
back into office if brexit is a live
question
so therefore from a tactical perspective
i think this is open and shut for
kiyosama but i also actually think it's
open and shut from a statesmanship
perspective right
i don't think that responsible parties
roll the dice
with economic shocks right and
ultimately if you vote against another
lady party you're rolling the dice with
an economic shock so i actually think it
is one of the things where both the
politics and the policy
are aligned and obviously that is
divisive in the labour party and there
are many reasons why
the lay party does not call my advice
but we have called for your advice today
and we're glad we did stephen bush
of the new statesman a pleasure to have
you on spectator
tv thank you for your time and your
expertise and we wish you a merry
christmas
merry christmas now before we move on to
the next segment of the show this is one
more reminder
to subscribe to the spectators youtube
channel for free
then you never miss a new episode of
spectator tv because you'll get an alert
just hit the subscribe button in the
bottom right corner of
the youtube screen now covet
no getting away from it at the end of
october wales went into a two-week
lockdown what it
dubbed a fire break at the time first
minister mark
drakeford celebrated his success
but the seven-day incidence rate had
almost halved but just a month after the
fire break ended
wales is in a critical situation once
again
at the end of november it was the only
part of the uk where infection rates
were
not falling now there's more talk of
another lockdown perhaps even
christmas being cancelled in the
principality so
did the fire break work or not i'm
joined by
a skeptic welsh conservative politician
andrew r t
davis he's also wales's shadow
health minister andrew davis welcome to
spectator
tv as well give us an overview of the
covert situation
in wales right now how serious is it
good afternoon andrew well it's pretty
bleak to say the least and it
cheers me no end to to actually be
sitting here
and ultimately being able to paint the
picture because ultimately what's
happened over the last three to four
weeks is
wales has been marginalized on the basis
that everyone's focused on the english
lockdown
when in fact the measures of the welsh
government have put me put put in place
to try and combat covid
over the last three months have been
nothing far short of disastrous
we've got high infection rates some
villages and towns with an infection
rate of over 1500 per 100
000 cases uh that by any estimation is
massive
and regrettably we now have this grim
statistics of having the highest death
count in the uk
as well as the highest infection rate so
in all counts the welsh government have
got a pretty grim record on all this
so in your view i'll come back to the
fire break in a minute and it's efficacy
or not
but in your view overall what has gone
wrong
well i think the issue has been that
they've changed the messaging so many
times to the autumn
originally we had a council area based
restriction
policy here in wales then we moved into
the fire break lockdown
then we also had restrictions between
travel between england and wales
then when we came out of the fire break
lockdown there was unlimited travel
across the whole of wales
uh whether you were in a high infection
rate or low infection rate
and then there was talk about possible
potential third lockdowns
and now we have the hospitality industry
shut down here in wales
and the public have just got so confused
with the messaging from the government
from a strong position that they had in
the summer which i'm perfectly willing
to pay credit to the welsh government
but they did have a good record
to talk about back in the summer they've
really thrown that away through the
ottomans and now
look pretty discredited in the eyes of
the public
we're going to put a chart up on the
screen on daily covert cases
in wales um it starts in september
and takes us up to roughly now
more like the end of uh november to be
more accurate
and within that you see the fire break
coming in
and that's marked from around the 25th
of november to the 8th of uh
december and what it shows
is that cases cases were rising pretty
fast
from well under for under 100 to
over 1200 the fire break comes in
and the cases do fall they don't fall
back to where they were but they fall
quite rapidly
the fire break ends and the cases start
to rise again
and as of this chart at the end of
november they're still rising
now many people looking at that chart
will say well the problem is
the the so-called fire break the
lockdown wasn't long enough what do you
say
well i disagree because the fire break
or lockdown
is no solution to the problem we find
ourselves in and we did put an
alternative plan forward for what we
believe would have been appropriate at
the time
so rather than just being in a position
of opposition to say you're doing it
wrong and offer no alternative
the issue is that many statisticians
point to the infection rate actually
dropping before the fire break came in
from infection rates from about the end
of october and it takes about a 14-day
period for that to feed through
but what we have are the contradictory
messages that's the real
fault line throughout this because the
public in wales generally do want to get
on top of this virus suppress it
but as i've highlighted the messaging
throughout the whole of the autumn
whether it be the fire break whether it
be the travel restrictions
whether it be the closure of the
hospitality industry have confused the
public here in wales
and with that confusion people have just
decided to go about their business in
the way that they see fit
and have lost faith in the government
and regrettably some communities have
been blighted more than other
communities
such as the numbers are holding up to
show at the moment and i should just
clarify i got my months
wrong there the fire break came in on
the 25th of october as you
or around then as you referred to as
october and then
came off around the 8th of november so
it straddled the end of
october in the beginning of november not
november into december as i've
as i said well as we look at the picture
uh now andrew davis the
the the graph is still rising um
and the number of cases is rising too so
what is to be if the fire break in your
view was not the right way
what is to be done now with christmas
bearing down on us
well win back the public's confidence is
a key part of what needs to be addressed
here because the public confidence is
draining away from the government
message
and i do believe that if that public
conference can be won back
and they start buying back into the
messages that will contain the virus
we can at least get to christmas and the
other side of christmas
the real risk as all commentators in any
part of the united kingdom are talking
about is what happens in january and
february and that is the unknown here
and i would defer to medical and
scientific opinion here
but it is my opinion that obviously
people have got greater confidence in
the future because the vaccine program
has been announced that we like all
parts of the united kingdom have been
undertaking vaccinations this week
and that will escalate as time goes on
but it is
down to the confidence that the public
have in the government
and we know that fire breaks and
lockdowns do not actually beat the virus
in themselves it's the measures that go
in tandem with that
and when you look at the travel
restrictions that have been put in place
by the welsh government for example
today in wales you cannot enter a
hospitality establishment
and have a drink yet you can jump in a
car and drive into an english tier 1 or
tier 2 area
have a drink in a pub and drive back to
wales that is the foolishness
of the government's messaging and that's
what's draining the confidence away from
the public
when they look at what's being asked of
them by the government ministers on
their daily press conferences
is there increasingly to a compliance
issue i mean i see the welsh police
have dealt with a thousand covert
related incidents
since the fire break um some reports in
the welsh press that compliance
is at an all-time low
indication of that is the infection rate
growing
the most quickly for the under 25s now
compliance is an issue
for the whole of the united kingdom but
is it particularly an issue in wales
it's a growing issue because again it
goes back to that confidence that you
might have or not in the government and
the way the government is handling
things
and if you go into any town or city or
village across wales today
you will see people going about their
business
many having regard for the regulations
but regrettably an increasing
larger minority who are if you like
reverting back to old habits and that in
itself is causing problems
as we know is feeding through into the
health service here in wales but i go
back to my fundamental argument as an
opposition politician here in wales
that was the welsh government did a good
job through the summer months
they've thrown that credit away through
the autumn with the mixed messaging
and the complete lack of bearing down on
the virus on a local basis
that has led to the situation we find
ourselves in today which is
the highest death rate in the united
kingdom the highest infection rate in
the united kingdom
and a pretty grim trajectory of the
virus spreading across communities in
wales what would you say to someone like
the swansea based director of public
health keith reed
he says that unless you lock down again
unless you lock down
the health system there will be
overwhelmed
well and he's speaking from a position
where his health board in the
announcement at the beginning of the
week was talking of at least 700 members
of staff being away absent because of
sickness and ill health we know this is
a pressure point
for the health service here in wales i
personally am skeptical about lockdowns
and fire breaks if they're dealt with
just in isolation because they do not
deal with the fundamentals of the virus
spreading within the community
and it goes back to this argument that i
keep projecting is about building that
confidence back in the community because
we know
in the last fire break regrettably
people move their hospitality activities
into domestic settings and that is the
most highly infectious
point that is has been pointed out by
many scientists and epidemiologists as
the breakdown of the virus
because it spreads because people lose
their discipline in that domestic
setting
and so i do re-emphasize i understand
the points of the public health and
people working in the nhs are bearing
down with at the moment
but the reality is the government in
wales have lost control of the virus
the health minister has lost the
confidence i would suggest of many
people in wales along with the first
minister
as was seen yesterday in comments about
blaming the people of wales for the
spread of the virus
rather than looking in the mirror and
maybe asking some searching questions of
themselves
and when you start blaming the people
are your customers
you are on a slippery slope and just
finally given the trajectory of covert
cases and many of the difficulties that
you yourself have alluded to
who you say even that is almost lost
control some areas
is there not a risk then that the welsh
government may feel it necessary
in effect to cancel christmas
well it's been alluded to both by the
health minister and the chief medical
officers
officer about more restrictions and
contingency planning
at this side of christmas although the
first minister himself in our session of
first ministers questions ruled that out
on tuesday
and if you like that goes to the heart
again of the point i'll be making right
the way through this interview
about the mixed messaging that's coming
out of government at the moment
you have the first minister saying
there's no chance of more restrictions
this side of christmas yet you have the
health minister in his press conference
on monday
along with the chief medical officer
yesterday talking about the potential
need for greater restrictions
we can all see the rising numbers and we
all want to get on top of this virus and
suppress the virus because
in its worst form regrettably it leads
to death
and we all know the consequences of long
covert as well so there are no easy
solutions here but
what's got to be done here is that
confidence rebuilt with people the
length and breadth of whales so that we
can feel that we can get through this
winter
and be in a better place in the spring
next year with the vaccination program
andrew arty davis shadow health minister
in wales thank you
uh for joining us on spectator tv today
uh and a merry christmas to you
thank you thank you very much andrew now
we stick with uh
covert and of course with vaccines juicy
was heralded
as v-day for the uk when the rollout of
the fisa vaccine started
kate andrews is our economics
correspondent she edits the spectators
daily covert 19 update email it is one
of the
biggest covered newsletters in the world
she joins me and now okay talk us
through
where we are with the vaccine in britain
now i saw the health secretary matt
hancock guy get quite emotional
uh about it he clearly thought this was
a turning point
yes he he got teary on breakfast tv
talking about this turning point and it
is a turning point
andrew i think we can definitively say
that every day now we are
taking steps to be closer to protecting
the vulnerable in the uk
margaret keenan was the first person to
get the pfizer jab on tuesday she's
turning
91 years old next week this
is one jab of 800 000 that are meant to
be administered in the coming weeks
that's four hundred thousand people
that are going to be inoculated and this
jab from pfizer is thought to be
effectively 95 this javelin pfizer is
thought to be 95
effective um so i think it's safe to say
that we are getting
a lot closer to protecting our
vulnerable but there's still a lot of
outstanding questions
as to the timeline how many vaccines the
uk is actually going to procure
how many more are going to come online
and how
we continue to learn to live with this
virus
because we're far away from saying that
everybody is safe
how seriously do we take these reports
of two nhs workers had a
quite severe reactions to the fisa
vaccine is that
just that's what happens there are a few
who do
or is it more serious than that uh well
when pfizer was running its safety tests
they did find that roughly one in a
thousand people might have had
an allergic reaction this is something
that can happen with all kinds of
vaccinations including
the flu jab there are warnings about
allergic reactions
i think the concern around this one it's
two nhs workers who had an allergic
reaction they're now thought to be
recovering
it was a short-term reaction it was by
no means fatal uh but the concern is
that the uk regulator
has now updated the guidance after
people started to receive
the jab and i i think it goes to this
broader point of how officials need to
be
really honest and transparent and
communicative
about the data and the safety around
this vaccine
polls across the uk show that certainly
over 50 percent
of the uk residents plan to take this
vaccine 60
70 depending on which pole you're
looking at and that's that's pretty good
data
and for those who are skeptical it's
usually not because they actually have
anti-vaxxer opinions but they just want
to know more about the safety
so i think you know incidents like this
speak to the fact that officials really
need to get out there and communicate
about why these jobs are safe the slight
risks that can be involved
but there's a great piece on the
spectator website right now from dr mark
toshner talking about how the risks are
extremely low and why it's a good idea
to get this vaccine
right well that's worth worth reading uh
kate bring us up to date now on
the oxford astrazeneca uh vaccine the
united kingdom has bought
already a hundred million dollars is a
lot more than it bought
on the pfizer one but where are we with
that
when do we think that can be rolled out
so if the oxford vaccine were to come
online we were we would more or less
have enough
doses of this vaccine to go around
certainly
to protect the vulnerable and those in
older age groups it's where the uk has
invested
most when it comes to these jobs but
it's becoming increasingly
complex when oxford first reported on
its efficiency rate it said it was
roughly 70 percent
effective but we found out uh when that
number was broken down
that it was 62 effective for the large
cohort court that had a certain kind
of dose given and then it was 90
effective
if the jabs were given in different
doses and so now they're questions and
the landsat has done a big report this
week
as to what a uk regulator can actually
approve
some of the questions are around age
perhaps they might approve it for the
under 55s
the 90 efficiency rate was only tested
on those under 55s
it's thought that they may need to go
back into a phase three
trial uh but the landsat highlights that
if this vaccine were to be between 60 to
80
effective its authors think that you
would still need certain kinds of social
distancing measures
uh ones that we know the prime minister
and i'm sure many people
perhaps the vast majority in the uk
would really like to throw out the
window
as soon as possible the idea of a
vaccine is that it is supposed to be
a silver bullet so one that isn't a
silver bullet is not going to be looked
as favorably on so there's still a lot
of outstanding questions around oxford
if and when it comes online it will be a
game changer as i said because hopefully
we could really speed up that timeline
for getting this vaccine out there and
injecting
lots of people but if it doesn't come
online for a while it does slow down the
process the uk
has invested in the pfizer vaccine the
moderna vaccine which hopefully comes
online soon
but by and large it's really relying on
oxford
and finally the economics of all this we
got the latest uh
uk gdp figures today showed the economy
growing for the
sixth consecutive month but it also
showed that growth was beginning to
peter out
by october nothing like the growth the
bounce back after
the horrendous uh fall in the economy in
march and april it would seem
looking at these figures that although
the economy may have been a bit more
resilient
than some might have thought it could
now be stagnating through november
into december and that we really need
the roll out of these vaccines early in
the new year if we're to see life
back in the economy again by easter
early summer
is that correct i fear it could be worse
than that andrew we saw the economy
start to stall in its progress in august
which was arguably the most
open month of the year when it comes to
covert restrictions the ability to
socialize and for shops
to be open and one of the reasons it's
stagnating is because
we've learned that if certain
restrictions are in place there's only
so much that an economy can
really recover but i think it's going to
do worse than stagnate it's very likely
that when we get november's figures
we're going to see another economic
contraction
albeit not nearly as big as what we saw
in april but england's second lockdown
and the force
re-closure of shops and non-essential
business is bound to have a bad
impact on the economy now a lot of these
forecasters say the good news is that if
vaccines come online
if we are inoculating millions of people
in the uk by next spring
thinks that we could be in a much better
position rolling back those social
distancing measures
and some forecasters have suggested we
should look to their optimistic
scenarios now
not their central scenarios which
usually on average show
the uk economy recovering by early 2022
as opposed to the end of 2022 and that
that is a big and meaningful
difference but it is going to require a
lot to happen with vaccines in a
relatively
short period of time and i think when we
look at the trajectory of 2020 because
we we know the vaccine's not going to
have that impact this year
you're going to see not a v-shape
recovery not a nike shape recovery but
actually quite a wonky w
because we are likely to have that
second economic contraction
which i'm just going to contemplate a
wonky w
economic correspondent father the
spectator thank you for being with us on
spectator tv
today now china has been vaccinating its
population
with unapproved vaccines since july
uh the estimate is that a million people
have been vaccinated
none of these jobs have received
regulatory approval
that may be why state media has been
relatively
hush about this vaccination program
cindy you is the spectators broadcast
editor she's host of our chinese
whispers podcast
which if you want to know what is
happening in china is a must listen
she writes about the vaccination program
on our coffeehouse website
this week cindy welcome uh to spectator
tv
just tell us a little bit about what's
been happening then i mean a million
people
is not a lot in a country the size of
china
nobody's really talked about it what
kind of vaccine is it
why a million who's doing it what do we
know
so andrew starting from the beginning as
you said this started in july
that was when china introduced this
legislative
loophole based on who emergency response
to ebola outbreak
which was basically saying you know in
an emergency situation you can vaccinate
frontline health workers frontline
transport workers and so on
what the new legislation has said in
china though is that if you're going
abroad
to high-risk countries you can also get
the vaccine
so what that means is that um the top uh
producers of vaccines in china there are
three of them sino-farm
which is a state-owned company sono vac
which is a private company
and cansano which is a military
developed one since july they've been
injecting people so cylo farm has been
injecting its own company employees
some of them are huawei employees as
well who go abroad
do these foreign contracts in different
countries and then some of them have
even come back and got into trouble with
uh with border control in shanghai
because they had antibodies that they
were detected
um and so cancino has been injecting
soldiers we don't know much about the
injections of these two companies
because they've been keeping relatively
quiet about who they're injecting and
how many or they sign a farm claims to
have injected nearly a million people
what i've been looking at in particular
is cynofax vaccination
they've been doing this uh in jersey
province which has some
57 million people as you say one million
is a drop in the ocean for that
um and the requirement there is to go
abroad or if you're one of these
frontline workers
what has happened is that on social
media this has caused something of a
millennial
uh ferrari because all people 20
somethings who study abroad
something of a rite of passage for young
chinese people these days they're all
clamoring for the vaccine
and in most of jo down province you have
to be a local resident in order to get
the vaccine but in this one tiny city of
one million people evil
you can get the vaccine as long as you
provide plane tickets some kind of proof
that you're going abroad
and so on social media everyone's
recommending evil as a place to go
how do you get on the waiting list um
how much does it cost
and all that sort of stuff because
they're not getting much guidance from
state media because
as you say national state media really
hasn't touched it at all
you'd think that this would be something
that global times the very jingoistic
nationalist
tabloid paper will be having a field day
on that china started vaccinating so
early
but they haven't and i think the reason
for that is because these vaccines
are in phase 3 trials the only reason
they're allowed to be rolled out is
because they count as
emergency vaccinations two questions
cindy is there any evidence of uh
untoward reactions to this vaccine i
mean
do we have any idea how this vaccine has
performed even though it hasn't finished
its full trial
yet and and if the chinese authorities
do have confidence in it despite the
trials not yet been completed
why only a million people um i think
those are good questions andrew so
on the first one uh the uae which is one
of the first countries in the world to
be rolling out so no farms
vaccine has said that it's 86 effective
but
none of the data has been released and
that was only yesterday
so we there's no you know peer review
for that there's no
verification process for that they claim
that no one has had adverse reactions
but one student i spoke to one 20
something year old who
studies in london but is in beijing when
he got vaccinated he didn't
leave contact details they haven't
contacted him since so
i don't know how these companies would
know if anyone did have an adverse
reaction because they're not
tracking it as far as i can see i guess
if you're more systematically getting it
because it's a place of work
then there might be more of a route
there more of a mechanism
and you know i think that china hasn't
wanted to do a mass roll-up because it
wants to see
how this vaccine goes china doesn't have
a great track record when it comes to
food and drug
safety viewers might have heard of the
2008
milk powder scandal where melamine
infused
baby formula hospitalized tens of
thousands of babies
so since then china has done a lot of uh
work on re
finessing that system but it was only
two years ago
when another vaccine manufacturer and
not any of the ones involved here was
fined over a billion dollars
for putting out default for putting out
40 rabies vaccines
so china doesn't have a great record on
it i think if i was sitting
right now i wouldn't necessarily want to
put my face on these vaccines
before they're approved and so that's
probably why it's only had a million
people
it's only rolling out in one province so
far although more may follow by the end
of the year
um because they're trying to see what's
going to happen with that
interestingly though last week's i know
farm did apply for regulatory approval
and so i wonder if the western vaccine's
progress has kind of
you know jolted them into waking up a
bit they could have done well they could
have
encouraged them to speed things up if
they
if the stage 3 trials are successful and
if if it gets
a clean bill of health is the chinese
state on standby
with massive stockpiles of this vaccine
i mean is it
ready to roll this out in huge numbers
and
uh even to the extent that it might
think of
exporting or licensing this vaccine
around the world absolutely so as well
as china starting emergency vaccination
as i mentioned uae has also started to
give an approval for
emergency vaccination so cyanofarm is
already exporting
to the uae countries from pakistan
to indonesia to brazil have been
striking deals with china to get these
vaccines and the interesting thing about
the chinese vaccines all three of them
are that they don't need to be uh in a
particularly cold temperature they don't
need to be minus 70
they just need to be at a relatively
easier temperature so for the developing
world
because it's going to be a mass produced
by china with its cape capacity and also
b
because it will be easier to store that
would be a much more preferable option
for poorer countries to deal with than
say the oxford vaccine
so so in that sense it is going to go
global
within china um there's a national
procurement scheme
and so one uh public health expert i
spoke to said that this might be why
companies are so keen to roll out their
vaccines now before they get approval
because once they get co-opted into the
state scheme they might not
get a say over their prices so they
might as well start cashing in now but
that's just his theory
all right cindy you spectators broadcast
editor
also the author of our podcast
chinese whispers always worth listening
to thank you for joining us at cindy
and that's it for this week thanks to
our other guests and once again
to our very special sponsor charles
stanley charles stanley is one of the
uk's
leading wealth management firms one of
the oldest firms on the london stock
exchange
remember subscribe to the spectators
youtube channel for free
then you'll never miss an episode of
spectator tv because
we'll warn you when one is coming up you
just have to hit the subscribe button at
the bottom
right hand corner it's free as always
please send any thoughts
to spectator tv at spectator dot co dot
uk we're always interested in what you
have as we try
to be better at this we're still pretty
new at the game and we hope you join us
again next thursday from what will
probably be the final
the week in 60 minutes of 2020.
until then goodbye
[Music]
you